i had to save my tricks for when i make
the second round man this win bad though
blame it on the wind again here we go
what's up y'all we're here in l.a with
coin cloud
i found this sport in south la that was
really cracked and beaten down
taking this katsuki technique to
renovating this basketball court was
kind of the dream that i've been
pursuing the whole time
we have a hot shot competition the first
round is for points
the second round is for money
all right y'all let's get to it
it's all start right there
we're putting 60 seconds on the clock
the two contestants with the most points
are going on to the championship round
what's up guys it's your girl jenna with
danny my name is brianna green my name
is rj hampton
what's going on i'm duncan robinson my
strategy right now i'm starting in and
closer on the basket you know rack up
some points
wind's blowing a little to the left and
i think i'm gonna just keep it close
i might just do you know like quantity
over quality might do a lot of ones
how to add up to ten you know there's a
lot of great talent out here today but
you know i think it's all about making
shots and being clutch
so it's anybody's day
[Music]
three two one go ahead
oh man there it is
start hot start
oh yeah we're going with the floaters
oh no okay here we go we got it we got
it play with it
all right let's go four four get in
go ahead and get that three now yeah
dunk yeah cheer it up okay
you going for my strategy 30 seconds
there you go
oh here i need that
ten nine eight
stay hot seven six
five oh four three
two one
what'd i get who got my score my last
uh yeah i don't know how much to reveal
okay
all right i feel like that's a good
first round get me to the second round
then i'll tie up the shoes and that's
how she's gonna lace
that was tough you know i'm a little bit
fatigued
it's anyone's day anyone's game how do
you feel bree
i feel all right so good still feel good
so me and bree we tied for round one
about to do a top of the key three-point
shootout see who moves onto the second
round so
i got me about to start
man this win bad dog
[Music]
[Music]
hey good luck out there now good luck
out there
hopefully she got all her makes out on
that one
[Music]
championship round we're playing for
cash to deposit into the coin cloud dcs
[Music]
i went first in the earlier competition
so i'm gonna take a back seat in this
one
we'll see what bree's got
three two one go well that's cash
oh wayne come on win
okay hey hey
you helped being six nine sure there you
go
i inspire you did i laughing
so
there you go let me get that 10 second
reminder yep
oh ten nine
eight three seven six
five four three
take your time
he doesn't walk off with it
i don't know what i had i wish i
out of the made but i feel good it
wasn't pretty
just had the idea go out there hit
singles you got it done
a lot of layouts that was the strategy
you know i feel good ladies and
gentlemen your winner of the coin cloud
shootout
duncan robinson do what it is
[Applause]
come on give me give me one bill
[Music]
you don't need it you don't need it i
got an extra 2 400.
straight cash i'm gonna use this coin
cloud digital currency machine
to convert it to some bitcoin
throw in my number you guys don't need
to see that back at home
oh there we go got the code i'm gonna
buy some bitcoin
digital wallet straight bitcoin
now i insert my winnings
that was easy that's 2400 in cash
converted to digital
currency my work here is done